This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
这是一个iHeart播客。保证是真人。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收看《艰难求知》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人科尔·盖茨。这个节目探讨的是黑男性的经历，进行一些在其他地方真的无法安全展开的坦诚对话，而你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人带着一套铠甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做，听听就知道了。
Turn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.
在AHA广播应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收看《艰难求知》。2023年，单身汉明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控生下了双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。成群的网络侦探才揭露了一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格，一个女同性恋。
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%.
迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的脑子都炸了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临后果。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《爱情陷阱》播客。2%。
That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO%. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
那是当旁边有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人所占的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧、体能训练以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立抗压能力的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你最终将成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。收听《2%》。即TWO%。在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。
When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他的最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。他会得到应有的惩罚。我们常说，相信你的闺蜜。在iheart radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《闺蜜：相信我，宝贝》。
Welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast, new listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here today. I am literally sitting in my room in a bikini. I just got back from the beach. And when I tell you that I raced home because I wanted to record this, I'm not even joking. I'm so excited for today's episode because today we are talking about the idea, the psychological construct of codependency and not just in romantic relationships, but also in other fundamental interpersonal relationships, particularly our friendships and with our family. I think that codependency can show up in so many facets of our social lives, and although
欢迎回到《20多岁的心理学》，在这个播客中，我们将探讨20多岁时的一些重大生活变化和转型，以及它们对我们心理意味着什么。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客，新听友们，老听友们，无论你们身在世界的哪个角落。今天很高兴有你们在这里。我真的穿着比基尼坐在我的房间里。我刚从海滩回来。当我告诉你我是飞奔回家因为我想录制这个节目时，我真的一点都没开玩笑。我为今天的节目感到非常兴奋，因为今天我们正在讨论这个想法，即共生依赖的心理结构，而且不仅在恋爱关系中，也在其他基础的人际关系中，特别是我们的友谊以及与家人的关系。我认为共生依赖可以表现在我们社交生活的许多方面，虽然
there is a healthy amount of dependency and very real reasons why that kind of turns into codependency, when it's taken to extremes, when it's uncontrollable, what can emerge are pretty, I would say, parasitic, symbiotic relationships that restrict our lives. It is a very nuanced idea and a very nuanced concept and I get this topic requested of me all the time, all the time, so it must be bothering some of us out there. And I honestly don't know why I haven't done it sooner, because it is such a crucial and a valuable discussion that needs to be had in this decade of our lives. I also think another reason I was really cool to almost do an episode on this, and the reason I wanted to discuss the idea of codependency is because I think that its meaning has been incredibly skewed
存在着健康的依赖程度，并且这种依赖转化为共生依赖有着非常真实的理由，但当它被推向极端、无法控制时，所产生关系的往往是——我会说——寄生的、共生的关系，这些关系会限制我们的生活。这是一个非常微妙的想法，也是一个非常微妙的概念，而且我一直都被要求探讨这个话题，一直都有人要求，所以它一定困扰着我们当中的某些人。我老实不知道为什么我没有早点做这个节目，因为这是在我们生活中的这十年里，一个非常关键且极有价值的讨论。我也认为我几乎想做一期关于这个的节目的另一个原因，以及我想讨论共生依赖这个想法的原因，是因为我认为它的含义已经被严重扭曲了
by misinterpretations on the internet, in pop culture, across social media, and when we use the term codependency, it's often really casual and flip it. And from the research that I've done, I've just come to realize it's so much more than that. So hopefully we can set the meaning straight in this episode and kind of dive into all of the psychology that is the basis of this concept and this idea, especially how it can become visible and can become a problem in our friendships and in our relationships and in our relationships. and in our relationships. So we're going to discuss, of course, the history behind the term codependency,
通过互联网、流行文化、社交媒体上的错误解读，当我们使用“共生依赖”这个词时，它通常非常随意且轻率。根据我所做的研究，我渐渐意识到它远不止于此。所以希望我们能在本期节目中弄清它的含义，并深入探讨构成这个概念和想法基础的所有心理学，尤其是它是如何在我们的友谊、关系以及人际关系中变得明显并成为一个问题的。在我们的关系中。所以我们当然要讨论共生依赖这个词背后的历史，
how it actually found its beginnings in AA meetings, of all places, how it shows up in our lives, how it manifests in our relationships, I guess also some of the warning signs and some of the causes of this experience of codependency, you know, specifically to do with our upbringing
它是如何在偏偏是戒酒互助会（AA）的会议中发迹的，它如何在我们的生活中表现出来，它如何在我们的关系中体现，我想还有这种共生依赖体验的一些危险信号和一些成因，你知道的，特别是与我们的成长经历
and childhood attachment. but I also want to talk about healthy dependency, interdependency, and what it really means to rely on, to love, and trust other people in a way that is sustainable and healthy in what that means for our lives. But if you're listening to this with a bit of fear, maybe that a relationship of yours is becoming codependent, not to worry, because I also really want to rehash
和童年依恋有关的。但我也想谈谈健康的依赖、相互依赖，以及在一种可持续且健康的方式下去依靠、去爱和信任他人究竟意味着什么，以及这对我们的生活意味着什么。但如果你在听这个时带有一点恐惧，也许担心你的某段关系正在变得共生依赖，不用担心，因为我也真的很想重新温习一下
some of the discussions that we've had before around boundaries and how to separate yourself and someone you may be codependent with and restore a healthy amount of reliance and support between you and another person. This topic is so relevant for our 20s. I feel like in this decade we are filled with so many emotions and deep feelings and realizations, but also insecurities. And quite frankly, things that we need help with, things that we haven't yet figured out. and the intensity of close relationships that we have in this decade,
我们之前围绕边界进行过的一些讨论，以及如何将你自己与可能与之共生依赖的人隔离开来，并在你与另一个人之间恢复健康的依赖和支持。这个话题与我们的20多岁极其相关。我觉得在这十年里，我们充满了那么多的情绪、深厚的情感和顿悟，但也充满了不安全感。坦白说，还有我们需要帮助的事情，我们尚未弄清楚的事情。以及我们在在这十年中拥有的亲密关系的那种强度，
be that platonic, with our family, or intimate, those relationships can be such a soothing band-aid almost for so many of our worries and concerns. But often when we cling to people in times of uncertainty, it can create problems. You know, I've had partners and friends who have been an absolute lifeline for me in periods of crisis. I felt like I couldn't live without them. but I think it's important to know when that is stepping into an unhealthy terrain and could actually potentially undermine what is best for us. So a discussion around codependency and how it
无论是柏拉图式的、与家人的，还是亲密关系，这些关系几乎可以成为我们许多担忧和顾虑的强效安慰剂。但通常当我们身处不确定时期紧抓着人不放时，它就会产生问题。你知道的，我曾有过一些伴侣和朋友，在危机时期他们绝对是我的救命稻草。我觉得没有他们我简直活不下去。但我认为重要的是要知道什么时候这正在跨入不健康的领域，并且实际上可能潜在地损害对我们最有利的东西。因此，关于共生依赖及其
manifests in the relationships we have, I think is so crucial. And if you can relate, well, you're definitely in the right place, I guess, and in for a treat because there's so much fascinating stuff behind the scenes of what we typically see or think of codependency. and so many things to, I guess, discuss and explore. So get ready, strap in. I am so excited for this deep dive and the discussion and all that is to come. Like we always do, let's start this discussion, this exploration, by getting our basics down pat.
在我们的关系中如何表现的讨论，我认为是至关重要的。如果你能感同身受，嗯，你绝对来对地方了，我想，你也有福了，因为在我们通常看到的或认为的共生依赖的幕后，有那么多迷人的东西，有那么多事情要——我想——去讨论和探索。所以准备好，系好安全带。我对这次深入探讨、讨论以及即将到来的一切感到非常兴奋。就像我们一直做的那样，让我们通过打牢基础来开始这场讨论、这场探索。
What is codependency and what is the psychological basis, I guess, behind its existence and presentation in our lives? So essentially codependency is an unhealthy, dysfunctional relationship that is unbalanced, whereby one person has assumed the role of the giver or the provider. There's someone who is willing to give and sacrifice everything for another person, whereas the other individual in this relationship is the taker. I think the first major element of this kind of relationship is that it is unhealthy. I think when we typically think about codependency as a society, as a community of people who have access to the internet and whatnot, we tend to imagine people who spend a lot of time together who are really inseparable. You know, you may have a best friend who you see every day and you do everything with and you talk for hours and you can't imagine your life without.
什么是共生依赖？它在我们生活中存在和表现背后的心理基础又是什么？所以本质上，共生依赖是一种不健康、失衡的、功能失调的关系，其中一个人承担了给予者或提供者的角色。总会有人愿意为另一个人付出和牺牲一切，而这段关系中的另一个人则是索取者。我认为这种关系类型的第一个主要元素是它是不健康的。我认为当我们作为一个社会、作为一个能够接触到互联网等资源的群体，通常想到共生依赖时，我们倾向于想象那些花很多时间在一起、形影不离的人。你知道的，你可能有一个每天都能见到、一起做所有事情、聊上几个小时、没有对方就无法想象生活的挚友。
That isn't inherently unhealthy or codependent if both people are equally reliant. on each other or the relationship is what we would call mutually beneficial. You know, there is a balanced level of support and compassion from both parties. It becomes unhealthy and it becomes codependent when the balancing act is distributed or disturbed and it shifts in one person's favour. You know, it's no longer even. And this is really important when we consider the second element of codependency, which is that all the relationships that are codependent are seen as one-sided, you know, one person being the giver, one person being the taker. That doesn't mean that both parties don't actually get something from the arrangement, because the relationship that they have struck
如果双方对彼此的依赖程度相当，或者这段关系是我们所说的互利关系，那么这本身并不是不健康的或共生依赖的。你知道的，双方有着平衡的支持和同情水平。只有当这种平衡行为被打破或扰乱，并且向着有利于某个人的方向倾斜时，它才会变得不健康并成为共生依赖。你知道的，它不再对等了。当我们考虑共生依赖的第二个要素时，这一点非常重要，那就是所有共生依赖的关系都被视为单方面的，你知道的，一个人是给予者，一个人是索取者。这并不意味着双方实际上没有从这种安排中获得任何东西，因为他们建立的关系
may mean that each is equally as dependent for different reasons. I don't think this is to make a generalisation about every codependent relationship. You know, I think when we talk about abusive relationships or abuse, we are moving away from simply codependency and sometimes they come hand in hand, especially when we consider emotional abuse. But I think most people who we would consider as codependent, the nature of their codependency rests on that truth, that both parties are receiving something, regardless of whether they recognize that consciously. For example, in any codependent situation, we have that giver, we have that taker, and each person has taken up one of those roles. That's essentially the equation of any
可能意味着出于不同的原因，双方的依赖程度是相等的。我并非要对每一种共生依赖的关系做出笼统的概括。你知道的，我认为当我们谈论虐待关系或虐待时，我们正在远离单纯的共生依赖，有时它们是形影不离的，尤其是当我们考虑到情感虐待时。但我认为我们认为具有共生依赖的大多数人，他们共生依赖的本质在于这个事实：双方都在接受某些东西，无论他们是否有意识地认识到这一点。例如，在任何共生依赖的情境中，我们都有那个给予者，我们有那个索取者，每个人都扮演了其中一个角色。这本质上就是任何
codependent relationship. And although I think we may take pity on the giver because they're being really self-sacrificing, maybe they're unable to set boundaries or they're exhausted by their counterparts need to take from them or be reliant on them, they may get some satisfaction from providing this one-sided support to the taker, or they may feel responsible for their partner or their parents or their friends and all that comes with that, their thoughts, their feelings and their actions. And in contrast, you know, the taker receives essentially unconditional love and support, you know, patience, money, forgiveness, whatever they need, and they are willing to, accept that. I think the term codependent, like I said, is often lobbied at people to describe them
共生依赖关系的等式。尽管我认为我们可能会同情给予者，因为他们真的在自我牺牲，也许他们无法设定界限，或者他们对对方从他们那里索取或依赖他们的需求感到筋疲力尽，但他们可能会从向索取者提供这种单方面的支持中获得一些满足感，或者他们可能会觉得对自己的伴侣、父母或朋友以及随之而来的一切负有责任，包括他们的想法、感受和行动。相比之下，你知道的，索取者基本上获得了无条件的情感支持，你知道的，耐心、金钱、宽容，无论他们需要什么，他们都愿意接受。我认为“共生依赖”这个词，就像我说的，经常被用来形容人们
as kind of needy or really clingy. But it is so much more than that. And it's often encouraged in some way, in some ways by the giver and also the taker as well, I guess, because they share in the responsibility and need for each other. I saw it described really well by this person called Dr. Legge in medical news today. And what they said essentially was that a codependent relationship occurs when one person needs the other who in turn needs to be needed. Like I said before, codependency, it's not just reserved for romantic relationships, as we may assume. It can really take place in any relationship which becomes unbalanced friendships, work relationships, family relationships, our parents, with our siblings, with our aunts and uncles, anyone that you have some kind of
有点需要人照顾或是真的很粘人。但它远不止于此。并且在某些方面，它往往在某种程度上受到给予者以及索取者的鼓励，我想，因为他们分担了彼此的责任和需求。我看到《今日医学新闻》上一位叫莱格博士的人对此做了很好的描述。他们的基本说法是，当一个人需要另一个人，而后者又反过来需要被需要时，共生依赖关系就产生了。就像我之前说的，共生依赖不仅仅局限于我们可能认为的恋爱关系。它确实可以发生在任何失衡的关系中——友谊、工作关系、家庭关系、我们的父母、我们的兄弟姐妹、我们的阿姨和叔叔，任何你与之有某种
social interaction with. I often think about the people who message me or tell me about friends of theirs who are absolutely reliant on them for all emotional support and they're constantly sacrificing their time and their energy to almost tend to this person. Whereas when they have problems or issues, that friend is never there for them. They're never willing to make those sacrifices. Their friend is completely dependent on them, whilst the other person just has to bear that and either can't do something or doesn't feel right about asking for that reciprocation. Withdrawing from that type of person, someone who is codependent on you, can be really, really difficult and we're going to talk about that later but interestingly before we jump into that I think
社交互动的人。我经常想到那些给我发信息或向我讲述他们朋友的人，这些朋友在所有的情感支持上绝对依赖他们，他们不断牺牲自己的时间和精力来几乎是照顾这个人。然而，当他们遇到问题时，那个朋友却从不在他们身边。他们从不愿做出那些牺牲。他们的朋友完全依赖他们，而另一个人却只能默默承受，要么无法做些什么，要么对于要求这种回报感到不太对劲。从这种类型的人——一个对你共生依赖的人——身边抽离出来，可能会非常非常困难，我们稍后会讨论这一点，但有趣的是，在我们深入探讨之前，我认为
some of the history is quite fascinating you know the term codependent or codependency it actually came out of research on the relationships between people who are suffering from addiction and the people that were close to them in their lives that's where the term first appeared amongst researchers who were studying people with addiction and they used it to describe the almost lopsided or, you know, one-sided enabling relationships between someone who was struggling, perhaps with alcohol abuse or substance abuse, and the people, you know, normally family and partners who feel that they have to give in to that person's struggles and they have to help them. Then it kind of moved its way into AA, Alcoholics Anonymous Meetings,
其中的一些历史非常迷人，你知道的，“共生依赖”或“共生依赖症”这个词实际上源于对患有成瘾症的人与他们生活中亲近之人的关系的研究。这个词就是从那里首次出现在研究成瘾者的研究人员当中的，他们用它来描述那些正在挣扎的人——可能与酒精滥用或物质滥用作斗争——与那些觉得不得不向那个人的挣扎妥协并必须帮助他们的其他人（通常是家人和伴侣）之间，几乎是失衡的或单方面的纵容关系。后来它慢慢进入了AA戒酒互助会的会议，
and then it kind of became a common term through that as it became more accessible to people. And I guess now it's been embraced by pop culture and pop, you know, and psychobabble to describe something that I think it really wasn't intended to represent. You know, essentially it was used to describe enabling relationships, you know, where one person is enabling another person's dependence on them or their dependence on something like drugs or alcohol.
然后随着它对人们变得更加普及，它通过这种方式变成了一个常用词。我想现在它已被流行文化和心理学黑话所接受，用来描述一个我认为它原本并不打算代表的事物。你知道的，本质上它过去是用来描述纵容关系的，你知道的，其中一个人在纵容另一个人对他们的依赖，或者对诸如毒品或酒精之类东西的依赖。
This actually really surprised me when I learned this because I think like most people, I had a very naive, I would say, understanding of what it was. I used it very casually, but it is a lot more severe and intricate than that. So now that we kind of know some of the history and what I would call the basic elements of a codependent relationship,
当我了解到这一点时，其实真的很吃惊，因为我想像大多数人一样，我对它是什么有着非常天真的理解。我曾很随意地使用它，但它比那要严重得多，也错综复杂得多。所以既然我们已经了解了一些历史以及我所说的共生依赖关系的基本要素，
you know that they're maladaptive, they're one-sided, they're unhealthy. I really want to provide a bit of an overview, I guess, of some of the warning signs in our own relationships, and those of people close to us as well, some of the things to look out for. I'm going to quickly state that although codependency is not something that you can be diagnosed with per se, if you see some part of yourself or your own experience in what I'm describing, what I'm going to talk about. There is a lot of professional help out there for you, and there are people that you can talk to.
你知道它们是适应不良的、单方面的、不健康的，我真的很想提供一个概述，我想，关于我们自己的关系以及我们身边的人的关系中的一些危险信号，一些需要注意的事情。我要快速说明的是，虽然共生依赖本身不能算作一种可以被诊断的病症，但如果你在我所描述的、我将要谈论的内容中看到了你自己或你自身经历的一部分。外面有很多针对你的专业帮助，也有你可以倾诉的人。
You know, you're not going to get a diagnosis or the person that you're speaking about isn't going to get a diagnosis. I think dependent personality disorder is probably the closest thing that we can get to, and that's essentially describing pervasive, you know, psychological dependence on other people in which someone is unable to be independent,
你知道的，你不会得到诊断，你所谈论的人也不会得到诊断。我认为依赖型人格障碍可能是我们能找到的最接近的东西，这本质上描述的是普遍存在的、你知道的，对其他人的心理依赖，在这种依赖中，一个人无法独立，
and unable to meet their own emotional needs or make decisions and needs to receive constant approval from others. And I guess that is, it's unlike codependency in that it doesn't involve reliance on just one person. But I think that like the general psychological community, you know, the DSM, it hasn't really caught up to the fact that dependent personality disorder and codependency are actually quite in hand in hand. And we speak a lot about codependency in terms of a disability.
无法满足自己的情感需求或做出决定，并且需要不断获得他人的认可。我想那是——它不同于共生依赖，因为它不涉及对仅仅一个人的依赖。但我认为像一般心理学界一样，你知道的，DSM（《精神疾病诊断与统计手册》）还没有真正跟上这样一个事实，即依赖型人格障碍和共生依赖实际上是息息相关的。我们经常在残疾的意义上谈论共生依赖。
but there still isn't that recognition that this is something that can really affect someone's psychological and physical and emotional well-being. So let's talk about some of the, I guess, warning signs, some of the things to look out for. Firstly, in codependent relationships, there is going to be an imbalance of power. If you are finding that you are giving much more energy, time, love, patience to another person who's really only using you for their own needs. That's probably the biggest indicator. So according to this clinical psychologist, I think their name was coder Derek or something like that, we may feel when we're in this situation, if we are the giver in this situation, like we have to save the person from themselves.
但仍然没有那种认知，即这可能是真正影响一个人心理、身体和情感健康的事情。所以让我们来谈谈一些，我想，危险信号，一些需要注意的事情。首先，在共生依赖的关系中，会出现权力失衡。如果你发现自己正在付出更多的精力、时间、爱、耐心给另一个人，而对方实际上只是为了满足自己的需求而利用你。这可能是最大的指标。所以根据这位临床心理专家的说法，我想他们的名字叫科德·德雷克（Coder Derek）之类的，当我们处于这种情境中时，如果我们是这种情境中的给予者，我们可能会觉得我们必须把这个人从他们自己手中拯救出来。
and we feel responsible for their emotional state and their well-being. You know, you take over their responsibility for themselves and you help them pick up the pieces. In that instance in which you feel responsible for someone else, they're not able to do it without you, they need you, and you're kind of stuck, you're in this situation where you're like, I'm so stressed, I've lost my independence, it's a probably, you know, a fairly big indicator, the relationship is moving towards codependence. Another huge indicator, and I feel like this is quite obvious, but I just feel like I need to state it for the record,
我们觉得对他们的情绪状态和福祉负有责任。你知道的，你接管了他们对自己的责任，你帮他们收拾残局。在这种情况下，当你觉得对别人负有责任，他们离开你就不行，他们需要你，而你有点卡住了，你处于这样一种情况：“我压力好大，我失去了独立性，”这可能是一个，你知道的，相当大的指标，表明这段关系正在走向共生依赖。另一个巨大的指标，我觉得这相当明显，但我只是觉得我需要为了记录而说明这一点，
is complete emotional exhaustion, even physical exhaustion. And what that comes from is essentially having to be responsible for another person, a grown adult, to the point that caring for yourself is almost the second priority, which it never should be. You know, the analogy I always use is that when a plane is crashing, when a plane is going down, you will never hear a flight attendant tell you to put the oxygen mask on someone else before yourself. And that goes for everyday relationships as well. You should always be helping yourself making sure that you are well before taking on that responsibility for others.
就是完全的情感耗竭，甚至体力耗竭。而这基本上源于不得不对另一个人——一个成年的成年人——负责，以至于照顾自己几乎成了第二优先事项，而这绝不应该是这样的。你知道的，我经常使用的类比是，当飞机失事时，当飞机正在下落时，你绝对不会听到空乘人员叫你把氧气面罩先戴在别人身上，而不是你自己。日常关系也是如此。在承担对他人的责任之前，你永远应该首先帮助自己，确保自己安好。
And if you're feeling like your relationship with that person is taking time away from yourself, you know, that you don't want to answer their calls or their text messages because it's going to be disastrous if you feel intense anxiety when they message you or you stop doing what you're doing, you interrupt your plans to see them or to help them. That's a huge sign that your relationship is codependent, especially if they don't do the same for you. I think it's worth acknowledging that when we are in these situations, it can be incredibly difficult to establish boundaries or even feel that we can put ourselves first because we are so wrapped up in our responsibility and our sense of loyalty to this other person,
如果你觉得你与那个人的关系夺走了属于你自己的时间，你知道的，你不想接听他们的电话或短信，因为那会是一场灾难，如果你在他们发信息给你时感到强烈的焦虑，或者你停下手头的事情，打乱你的计划去见他们或帮助他们。这是一个巨大的信号，表明你们的关系是共生依赖的，特别是如果他们不对你做同样的事情的话。我认为值得承认的是，当我们处于这些情况下时，建立界限甚至觉得自己可以把自我放在首位可能会极其困难，因为我们太深陷于对另一个人的责任感和忠诚感中了，
especially if, you know, they're your romantic partner or if they're your mother or your father or your sibling or your best friend. And I did a whole episode on kind of how to move forward from this called, I think it's like about setting boundaries and sticking to them. and I think that's really relevant here. So if you are really struggling, go and listen to that around setting boundaries with someone if it is a really emotionally tumultuous situation. But there is a few more signs that I guess I just want to go through really quickly and which I think are so worth bringing up here. A lot of the signs that we've talked about so far have been how the giver feels, you know,
特别是如果，你知道的，他们是你的恋爱伴侣，或者如果他们是你的母亲、父亲、兄弟姐妹或挚友。我曾做过一整期关于如何从中走出来的节目，好像叫做，大致是关于设定界限并坚持下去。我认为这在这里真的很相关。所以如果你真的在苦苦挣扎，去听听那一期关于如何在情绪极其混乱的情况下与某人设定界限的内容吧。但还有一些其他的信号，我想我只想快速过一遍，我认为非常值得在这里提出来。到目前为止我们讨论过的大多数信号都是关于给予者的感受，你知道的，
that you might feel like your life revolves around this person. You don't have your own space. You feel, you know, stuck. You feel guilty. you feel shame. But in terms of the taker, there are some people who are in co-dependent relationships who are taking from someone else who might have that realization of like, this actually isn't healthy for me and it isn't healthy for them.
你可能会觉得你的生活围绕着这个人转。你没有自己的空间。你觉得，你知道的，被困住了。你感到内疚。你感到羞耻。但就索取者而言，有些处于共生依赖关系中的人，他们从别人那里索取，可能会意识到“这对我不健康，对他们也不健康”。
So these people, they may really struggle with being alone and also feeling alone. They blame the other person for all that is wrong in their life. They say things like I couldn't live. without you, their behavior might actually escalate in severity when you do try to set boundaries or you do try and pull away. They may use guilt against you or maintain a pretty strong sense of victimhood, even sometimes placing you as the villain. And all of this is really manipulative. But it doesn't always come from a place that wants to be cruel or come from a place that wants to be cruel or come from a place that wants to be manipulative.
所以这些人，他们可能非常难以忍受独处，也难以忍受感到孤独。他们把生活中的一切错误都归咎于另一个人。他们说诸如“没有你我活不下去”之类的话，当你试图设定界限或试图退缩时，他们的行为实际上可能会升级得更加严重。他们可能会对你使用内疚牌，或者保持相当强烈的受害者心态，甚至有时把你塑造成恶人。所有这一切都具有极强的操纵性。但这并不总是出于想要残酷的动机，或者出于想要残酷的动机，或者出于想要操纵的动机。
It can also just be that they actually don't have a strong support system. They don't trust other people. And, you know, the sad truth is that people will only treat you the way that you allow them. So this pattern of behavior may have developed over a long period of time in which boundaries have not been well established or they haven't been respected. And it's not to victim blame or blame any. anyone or assign any stigma to either member of this kind of relationship, you know, vulnerability and relationships, even addiction, as we were saying before, they're really complex and they're really sensitive things. So if you're relating to any of this, either in a relationship with
也可能只是因为他们实际上没有一个强大的支持系统。他们不信任其他人。而且，你知道的，悲伤的事实是，别人对待你的方式都是你允许的。所以这种行为模式可能经过了很长一段时间的发展，在此期间，界限没有建立好，或者没有得到尊重。这并不是为了责怪受害者，也不是为了责怪任何人，或者给这种关系的任何一方贴上耻辱的标签，你知道的，关系中的脆弱性，甚至成瘾，正如我们之前所说，它们是非常复杂且敏感的事情。所以如果你与其中的任何一点产生共鸣，无论是在与
your partner or your friend, whoever, please don't blame yourself for this kind of relationship. I think we are all just trying our best with what we have, but I think that it is really important to understand and be aware of what this means for us. And I think many of the signs are also what we would call the consequences of codependency. Often, if you were a clinical psychologist and someone came to you and said, my partner is so reliant on me anytime anything goes wrong they need me to be there for them I support them financially they don't have any other friends but when I need support they push me away they're going to look at you and say oh that's codependent you know there's a lack of separation
你的伴侣还是朋友的关系中，无论跟谁，请不要为这种关系责怪你自己。我想我们大家只是在用我们所拥有的东西做出最大的努力，但我认为理解并意识到这对我们意味着什么真的很重要。而且我认为许多信号也是我们所说的共生依赖的后果。通常，如果你是一名临床心理学家，有人来找你并说：“我的伴侣太依赖我了，每当有事情出错，他们都需要我在那里支持他们，我在经济上支持他们，他们没有其他朋友，但当我需要支持时，他们却把我推开，”他们会看着你并说：“哦，那是共生依赖，”你知道的，缺乏分离感，
there's a lack of individuality of healthy coping mechanisms or independence and like I just mentioned it may even result in the giver often giving up money or resources for the other person. And there is, of course, that element of control, which we may associate with the taker, but actually, either party in this relationship can promote this to the point where it becomes unnatural and unhealthy. So why do these relationships happen? They sound quite unnatural, I would say. I think it's rare to see a full-blown, codependent relationship in, you know, everyday life. They definitely still exist. So why is it that some people find themselves in such a toxic cycle.
缺乏个性、健康的应对机制或独立性，正如我刚才提到的，它甚至可能导致给予者经常为另一个人放弃金钱或资源。当然，还有控制的要素，我们可能会将其与索取者联系起来，但实际上，这段关系中的任何一方都可以推波助澜，直到它变得不自然和不健康。那么，为什么会发生这些关系呢？听起来相当不自然，我想说。我认为在日常生活中很少看到完全成熟的共生依赖关系。它们绝对仍然存在。那么，为什么有些人会发现自己陷入如此有害的循环中呢？
Well, as the origins of, you know, the term codependency suggests, a huge risk factor or contributor is the presence of addiction in one or even both members. There was a study conducted in 2014 and it found that people who were surveyed who had a family member or a personal history of addiction, particularly with alcohol, they were more likely to report that they had been in a codependent relationship or that they had been codependent on someone else. And this study also examined whether men or women were more susceptible to codependency. And interestingly, these relationships were just as common within men and women, within both genders.
好吧，正如“共生依赖”这个词的起源所暗示的那样，一个巨大的风险因素或促成因素是其中一名甚至双方成员都存在成瘾问题。2014年进行的一项研究发现，接受调查的人中，如果有家庭成员或个人有成瘾史（尤其是酒精成瘾），他们更有可能报告说自己曾处于共生依赖关系中，或者曾对其他人产生共生依赖。该研究还探讨了男性还是女性更容易产生共生依赖。有趣的是，在男性和女性中，在两性之间，这些关系同样普遍。
That kind of surprised me, I will say, because I think that women are often very much stereotyped as being more nurturing and natural caregivers and really bad at setting boundaries, whatever you want to say. But I think that in these scenarios, really in these situations, everyone is just as susceptible as the next regardless of gender. The fact is that determine these kinds of relationships have a lot more to do with things like your childhood. You know, having a history of abuse or abandonment. That's a lot. a huge predisposing risk factor because often that means that that person, whoever it may be, has not been taught what a healthy, mutually beneficial relationship looks like.
我得说，这确实让我有点吃惊，因为我认为女性常常被刻板印象化为更具养育本能、天生的照顾者以及很不擅长设定界限，随便你想怎么说。但我认为在这些情境中，真正处于这些情况下，无论性别如何，每个人都同样易受影响。事实是，决定这类关系的东西与诸如你的童年之类的事情有很大关系。你知道的，有虐待或遗弃史。这是一个巨大、巨大的易感风险因素，因为通常这意味着这个人，无论他是谁，都没有被教导过健康、互利的关系统计起来是什么样子的。
Remember how we learn to treat people and be treated is very much modelled on how our parents or our early caregivers conducted their relationships or treated us. and people who have unfortunately experienced abuse or abandonment, they themselves become more at risk of finding themselves in a codependent relationship, either as the giver or the taker, depending on what they lacked or had experienced in childhood. Honestly, I think like many problems like codependency, the root of this problem, the cause of this problem,
请记住我们如何学习对待他人以及如何被对待，很大程度上是以我们的父母或早期照顾者如何处理他们的关系或对待我们为模范的。那些不幸经历过虐待或遗弃的人，他们自己更有可能发现自己陷入共生依赖关系中，无论作为给予者还是索取者，这取决于他们在童年中缺少了什么或经历了什么。老实说，我认为就像共生依赖这样的许多问题一样，这个问题的根源，这个问题的起因，
is our upbringing and our family or childhood environment, especially if they were dysfunctional or they didn't provide our core emotional needs. And generally speaking, our attachment style patterns that were developed in early childhood are really going to influence whether or not we end up in this kind of scenario. With all of that in mind, what I really want to discuss next is the distinction between codependence and a healthy level of dependency that we we would expect to see in our relationships. I think I've spent the large majority of this first bit of this episode really kind of drilling into our minds how terrible this can be and how maybe we shouldn't rely on someone or we don't want to be deemed as codependent or too
是我们的成长经历以及我们的家庭或童年环境，特别是如果它们功能失调或者没有提供我们的核心情感需求。总的来说，我们在幼年时期发展出来的依恋风格模式，确实会影响我们最终是否会陷入这种情境。带着所有这些想法，我接下来真正想讨论的是共生依赖与我们在关系中期望看到的健康依赖水平之间的区别。我想我花了这个节目第一部分的大部分时间，真的在我们的脑海里灌输这有多么糟糕，以及也许我们不应该依赖某人，或者我们不想被视为共生依赖或过于
close. Obviously that is not true. So I really want to discuss that distinction between codependence and healthy dependence or interdependency. Before we kind of outlined some strategies for disentangling or distancing ourselves from codependent relationships. Our next partner has a product I use literally every day. I started taking AG1 because I've been on a bit of a health journey. I wanted to take better care of my immune system and my gut health. And with one delicious scoop of AG1, you're essentially absorbing 75 high quality vitamins, minerals, probiotics, all that good stuff.
亲密。显然那不是真的。所以我真的很想讨论共生依赖与健康依赖或相互依赖之间的区别。在我们概述一些用于剥离或与共生依赖关系保持距离的策略之前。我们的下一个合作伙伴拥有一款我几乎每天都在使用的产品。我开始服用AG1是因为我一直在进行一段健康之旅。我想要更好地照顾我的免疫系统和肠道健康。只需一美味勺AG1，你基本上就能吸收75种高质量的维生素、矿物质、益生菌以及所有这些好东西。
And it's really great for your nervous system and your immune system. It's just one simple micro habit that you can incorporate into your daily life with big benefits. It's super lifestyle friendly. And Athletic Greens is also a climate neutral certified company, which we absolutely love on the show. Right now, it is time to reclaim your health and arm your immune system with a convenient daily nutrition. It's just one scoop in a cup of water every day. That's it. No need for a million different pills and supplements to look after your health.
这对你的神经系统和免疫系统真的很好。这只是一个你可以融入日常生活的小习惯，却有着巨大的好处。它非常适应生活方式。而且Athletic Greens也是一家获得气候中和认证的公司，我们在节目中绝对热爱这一点。现在，是时候通过便捷的每日营养来重塑你的健康并武装你的免疫系统了。每天只需在一杯水中加一勺。就是这样。无需成百万上万种不同的药丸和补充剂来照顾你的健康。
And to make it easy, Athletic Greens is going to give you a free one-year supply of immune-supporting vitamin D and five free travel packs with your first purchase. All you have to do is visit athletic greens.com slash gemma. Again, that's athletic greens.com slash gemma to take ownership over your health and pick up the ultimate daily nutritional insurance. A healthy amount of reliance on someone else for support, for encouragement, And love is absolutely normal. In fact, I think it would be more worrying to me if we were completely detached from others and could never rely on someone else to fulfill some aspect of our emotional needs.
为了方便起见，Athletic Greens将在你首次购买时为你提供一年的免费免疫支持维生素D和五包免费旅行装。你所需要做的就是访问athletic greens.com斜杠gemma。再次重申，那是athletic greens.com斜杠gemma，以掌控你的健康并挑选终极的每日营养保险。对某人进行健康水平的依赖以获得支持、鼓励，
We're social beings. We are pack animals, a tribal species at our core. And what that means is that we crave and we need connections with others. We need trust between ourselves and other people to thrive. So where can we draw the line between dependence and its evil twin, you know, codependency? I think the key distinction can be summed up in one word. Mutual. Mutual love, mutual support, mutual respect, mutual energy, mutual time.
和爱绝对是正常的。事实上，如果我们完全与他人脱节，从不依赖他人来满足我们情感需求的某些方面，那对我来说反而会更令人担忧。我们是社会性动物。我们是群居动物，本质上是一个部落物种。这意味着我们渴望并需要与他人的联系。我们需要自己与他人之间的信任才能蓬勃发展。那么我们可以在依赖与其邪恶双胞胎——你知道的，共生依赖——之间划清界限呢？我认为关键的区别可以用一个词来概括。相互。
Healthy dependence, it involves a mutual give and take. It's not one-sided. Both people are able to receive the support and the incumption. encouragement and the practical help that they need. And of course there are going to be times in which you're going to have to support, you know, the other person more. Are they going to have to support you more than you're supporting them? You know, if your parent or your sibling is really sick, it makes sense that you may be doing more of the emotional and physical labor for them at that time. That is nothing to shy away from. That is not the point of this episode. You know, life is very much
相互的爱、相互的支持、相互的尊重、相互的精力、相互的时间。健康的依赖，它涉及相互的给予和索取。它不是单方面的。双方都能够获得他们所需的支持、鼓励和实际帮助。当然，有时你将不得不更多地支持，你知道的，另一个人。他们是否必须比你支持他们更多地支持你？你知道的，如果你的父母或兄弟姐妹病得很重，那么你在那个时候为他们做更多的情感和体力劳动是合乎情理的。这没什么好回避的。这不是本期节目的重点。你知道的，生活在很大程度上
defined by its uncertainty and its ups and downs. and it's okay if you need someone a little bit more at times, you know, if you're going through a bit of a crisis or something else is going on, that's healthy. It's okay for our relationships to kind of peak and troth and to sometimes need people more than they need you. But if that's happening all the time, that's a problem. I think having a healthy level of dependence on others, like I explained, you know, being able to have that give or take, depending on what the other person is going through being able to call on the people in your life for support, it's actually really positive. I don't feel like I need to say that, but it does have a lot of proven clinical benefits
由其不确定性和起伏定义。如果你有时需要别人多一点，你知道的，如果你正在经历一些危机或其他正在发生的事情，那是健康的。我们的关系出现起伏有时需要别人多于别人需要你是正常的。但如果这种情况一直发生，那就是个问题。我认为对他人保持健康的依赖水平，就像我解释的那样，能够有给予或索取，取决于另一个人正在经历什么，能够呼叫你生活中的人寻求支持，对我们的福祉和对生活的整体看法实际上是非常积极的。我觉得我不需要说出来，但它确实对我们的福祉和整体生活观有很多经过验证的临床益处。
for our well-being and our overall outlook on life. They contribute to our sense of reliance, our resourcefulness. We have a stronger sense of trust in our own abilities. We are better at expressing our needs and our emotions, and we have greater self-esteem when we're able to promote healthy independence and healthy dependence in our relationships. And that all sounds really positive because it is, it's healthy and it's something that we can pursue. But when it emerges as a problem is when you are unable to detach, you need something else for your support. You know, this person is everything to you or you're giving someone else everything of you. beyond what could possibly be expected in any situation.
它们有助于增强我们的依赖感、变通能力。我们对自己的能力有更强的信任感。我们更擅长表达自己的需求和情感，当我们在关系中能够促进健康的独立和健康的依赖时，我们会拥有更高的自尊。这听起来都很积极，因为它的确是，它是健康的，是我们能够追求的东西。但当它表现为一个问题时，就是你无法脱离，你需要别的东西来支持。你知道的，这个人对你来说就是一切，或者你把你的全部都给了别人。超出了任何情况下可能合理预期的程度。
And we have to remember here that codependence is maladaptive and it's harmful to both members of the relationship. I read an incredible article that explained this distinction really well and it explained the distinction between codependence and independence or interdependence more like it as helping versus enabling. If you think that your relationship with someone has fallen into, into a giver and a taker situation, ask yourself whether your actions and your responses to them are helping them or enabling them. You know, if your friend keeps coming to you for money but
我们必须在这里记住，共生依赖是适应不良的，并且对关系中的双方都是有害的。我读到了一篇不可思议的文章，它很好地解释了这种区别，它解释了共生依赖与独立或相互依赖之间的区别，更像是帮助与纵容。如果你认为你与某人的关系已经陷入了给予者和索取者的境地，问问自己，你的行动和对他们的反应是在帮助他们还是在纵容他们。你知道的，如果你的朋友一直来找你借钱，但
never paying you back or showing any progress towards being financially independent, this may seem like you're helping them at the surface level. You know, you're helping them through a tough time, but it actually may be that you're enabling their dependency on you for assistance. I always try and frame my decisions around whether my actions are helping someone to become self-sufficient or whether I'm doing it for myself because I want to feel better. You know, or I'm helping them to the point that they, you know, they don't need to help themselves and they don't need to help me, right? Like they're just relying on me for something and they're not able to take responsibility for their problems.
从表面上看，这可能像是你在帮他们度过难关。你知道的，你是在帮他们渡过难关，但实际上，这可能是在助长他们对你的依赖。我总是试图这样来决定我的行为：我的行动是在帮助某人变得自力更生，还是我这么做只是为了让自己感觉好受一点？你知道的，或者我是不是在帮他们到那种他们根本不需要自立，也不需要帮助我，对吧？就像他们只是在某事上依赖我，而无法为自己的问题承担责任。
That's a really tricky situation to be in. And I don't think we need to apply that perspective to all of our relationships, but it is something to be cognizant of. Doesn't mean you need to say no or that you can't help someone out in a tricky situation. But when it starts to look like enabling behavior, it probably isn't helping either of you. maybe you're listening to this and you're like, this is me, this is me, I'm in this situation, I'm really struggling and you've been able to identify yourself as being in a codependent situation, whether that is with a parent, with a romantic partner, with a friend, it really doesn't matter. So how do we move back to a healthy level of interdependency and dependence?
处在这样的情况真的很棘手。我不认为我们需要把这种视角套用到所有的关系中，但这是我们需要意识到的事情。这并不意味着你需要拒绝，或者你不能在别人遇到棘手情况时伸出援手。但当它开始表现为一种纵容行为时，可能对你们双方都没有好处。也许你正在听这段播客，心里想着：这就是我，这就是我，我正处在这种境况中，我真的感到很挣扎。而且你已经能够意识到自己正处于一种共生关系中，无论这种关系是和父母、浪漫伴侣还是朋友，这其实并不重要。那么，我们该如何回归到健康的相互独立和依赖状态呢？
and how do we restructure our relationship with that person so that it doesn't compromise our identity. It doesn't compromise our self-esteem or, you know, our entire lives, our welfare. Healing a relationship from codependency, it's going to take time because it's like separating out someone's addiction to you, you know, fighting against your addiction to them.
我们又该如何重构与那个人的关系，才不至于危及我们的自我认同？才不至于危及我们的自尊，或者我们的整个生活与福祉。从共生关系中治愈一段关系需要时间，因为这就好比戒除别人对你的瘾，你知道的，这就像是在对抗你对他们的瘾。
All of that is exhumored. exhausting. It's also neurologically very difficult because when we do become reliant on anything, be that a drug or a person in this situation, what happens to our brain is that our neurons and our synaptic pathways, they become wired towards wanting that person or whatever it is that we're addicted to. It's a process called long-term potentiation, whereby the more that we activate a certain pathway, the stronger it becomes. And the harder it is to break that pattern or consumption. And when those pathways are no longer activated, you know, when someone is having a problem and they go, oh my gosh, I cannot call that person. Or when someone calls you with a problem and
所有这些都让人精疲力竭。从神经科学的角度来看，这也是非常困难的，因为当我们对任何事物产生依赖时无论是药物还是这种情况下的某个人，我们大脑发生的变化是，我们的神经元和突触通路会朝着渴望那个人的方向连线，或者渴望我们上瘾的任何东西。这是一个被称为“长期增强”的过程，通过这个过程，我们激活某个通路的次数越多，它就会变得越强大。要打破这种模式或消费行为也就越困难。当这些通路不再被激活时，你知道的，当某人遇到问题，然后他们说：天哪，我不能打电话给那个人。或者当有人打电话向你倾诉问题而
you go, oh my gosh, I can't help you because this is unhealthy, it's distressing. The first step I think I would always recommend is to get some outside help or an outside and objective perspective on the relationship in question and the problem that you're facing. It can be very difficult to be honest with ourselves when a situation is so emotionally charged and at times probably even tense or dangerous. So going to, you know, a trusted friend, a mentor, a mental health professional based on whatever resources you have. Just someone who's separate from the situation, it's sometimes really important
你说：天哪，我帮不了你，因为这很不健康，这让人痛苦。我认为我总是会推荐的第一步，是为所讨论的关系以及你所面临的问题寻求一些外部帮助，或者一个外部的、客观的视角。当一种情境充满强烈的情感色彩，有时甚至紧张或危险时，要对自己诚实是非常困难的。因此，你可以去找一个值得信赖的朋友、导师、心理健康专家，这取决于你手头有什么资源。只要是局外人就行，有时这真的很重要，
because it gives you a logical bird's eye view so you can see clearly why this scenario is hurting you, why it's hurting the other person, why it's probably really good if you get some space. And, you know, they may also just have some really good advice and they may be able to provide some options to you that you haven't considered. The next step that I think is important is to ground yourself
因为它能给你提供一个合乎逻辑的鸟瞰视角，让你能清晰地看到为什么这个剧本正在伤害你，为什么它在伤害另一个人，为什么如果你能腾出一些空间会是一件非常棒的事。而且，他们也可能会提供一些很好的建议，并能为你提供一些你从未考虑过的选择。我认为重要的下一步是让自己脚踏实地，
in why you have acknowledged that this is maladaptive and unhealthy and find a way to make your thoughts and your feelings on the matter tangible. I think this applies to even situations beyond codependency. Any problem that you have, anything you're trying to solve, making a notes list or journaling to yourself about how you feel, why this is difficult, why you want to change, it's so much easier to motivate yourself or to move through a difficult transition when you have some written reminder about why you need to do something,
明确你为什么承认这种关系是不适应且不健康的，并找到一种方法，将你对此事的想法和感受变得具体可行。我认为这甚至适用于共生关系之外的情况。你遇到的任何问题，你试图解决的任何事情，做一份笔记清单，或者写日记记录你的感受、为什么这很困难、为什么你想改变，当你有了关于为什么你需要做某事的书面提醒时，激励自己或度过一段艰难的转型期就会容易得多。
why you are making that change. This list, you know, might include things in this situation, like, I don't like how I'm feeling stuck. Or in this relationship, I'm not able to promote my independence, or I'm not able to be independent. Or situations, or statements about how the situation is making you feel and why it needs to change. And that way, you can come back to it whenever you feel yourself slipping back into old pabits or old patterns. I think the next really valuable step to take, and if you've listened to my Boundaries episode, this may sound really familiar, it's to confront the person and to confront the problem
为什么你要做出这种改变。在这种情况下，这个清单可能包括：我不喜欢自己这种卡住的感觉。或者在这段关系中，我无法促进我的独立，或者我无法保持独立。或者是关于这种情况如何让你感觉以及为什么需要改变的陈述。这样一来，每当你发现自己不知不觉又陷入旧习惯或旧模式时，你就可以重新翻看它。我认为接下来非常有价值的一步是，如果你听过我的“界限”那一集，这听起来可能会非常熟悉，那就是去面对这个人，去面对问题，
and have an honest conversation. I know it's really scary. I've done it before. It is terrifying. But I think one of the worst feelings in the world is when someone makes a decision without consulting you or completely ghosts to you or shuts you out. Obviously that's necessary sometimes and there are people who are just really bad for our health and you can make that call based on your own personal appraisal of the situation or the extent of, of the codependency, but if the situation allows it, I personally believe it's actually quite almost cruel, I think, to leave someone with no explanation or discussion. And you don't need to treat it as a two-way street or like the decision is up for debate. Just simply lay out the facts and your feelings and why you feel like you would both benefit from this, why you would like
进行一次诚实的对话。我知道这真的很吓人。我以前做过。这太可怕了。但我认为世上最糟糕的感觉之一，就是别人在没有跟你商量的情况下做出决定，或者彻底人间蒸发、把你拒之门外。当然，有时这是必要的，有些人对我们的健康确实百害而无一利，你可以根据自己对情况的私人评估或共生关系的程度来做出这种判断，但如果情况允许，我个人认为，把一个人晾在那里不作任何解释或讨论，其实几乎是残忍的。你不需要把它当成双向交流，也不需要把这个决定拿出来争论。只需简单地陈述事实和你的感受，以及为什么你觉得你们俩都会从中受益，为什么你希望
your situation to change, and leave it at that. Leave it at that. You don't need to answer questions. You don't need to justify anything. And that person may actually surprise you and say, you know, like, I've actually been feeling this way as well. And I want our relationship to be healthier. Or, you know, I want this for us. But I think honesty is always the best policy in emotionally sensitive situations, whatever they may be. I think now comes the difficult part, which is sticking to your guns, respecting your own boundaries,
你的状况能够改变，然后点到为止。就这样。你不需要回答问题。你不需要证明任何事情的合理性。那个人实际上可能会给你一个惊喜，并对你说：你知道吗，其实我一直也是这么想的。我希望我们的关系更健康。或者，你知道的，我也希望我们能这样。但我认为在情感敏感的情况下，无论情况如何，诚实永远是上策。我想现在最困难的部分来了，那就是坚持你的立场，尊重你自己的界限，
is learning to say no when that person pushes up against what you have decided to do. It's okay to fail a few times to find, you know, that separation hard or even painful. Like I said, you're neurologically and physically inclined to feel this way. But if as the giver, you're still answering their calls at any time of the night, or as the taker, you're finding that your emotional state is based on how that person is treating you or the attention they're giving you and you cannot fight that urge, then the boundary I don't think has been fully set, or it hasn't been fully respected.
当那个人试图突破你所决定的界限时，学会说“不”。偶尔失败几次，发现保持这种分离很难甚至很痛苦，这是没问题的。就像我说的，你的神经和生理本能就会让你有这种感觉。但如果你作为给予者，仍然在夜里的任何时间接听他们的电话；或者作为索取者，你发现自己的情绪状态完全取决于那个人如何对待你或他们给予你的关注，而你无法克制这种冲动，那么我认为这个界限还没有完全建立，或者它还没有被完全尊重。
So make some non-negotiables or some rules for yourself in these situations, and I mean rules, not things that you would like to do, but tangible decisions you're going to be accountable to yourself for. It might also help to have someone else who can kind of help you stay on track or who you can kind of answer to or update them on your progress and who can help you kind of question your decisions, not necessarily make you feel guilty, but make you appreciate the reasoning behind maybe why you're struggling
因此，在这些情况下，为自己制定一些不容妥协的底线或规则，我说的是规则，而不是你希望去做的事情，而是你要对自己负责的具体决定。找另一个人来帮你保持正轨，或者你可以向他们汇报、向他们更新你的进展，并能帮你审视自己的决定（不一定是为了让你感到内疚，而是让你理解为什么自己可能在苦苦挣扎的背后原因），这或许也会有所帮助，
to keep that boundary. After a slip-up, whatever it may be, it's also really crucial to reflect on how it's left you feeling. You know, did you let someone back into your life in the way that you didn't necessarily want, or if you felt that you came back to someone, you didn't want to be reliant on, don't suppress that feeling. Don't suppress that shame almost. Sit with it. Process it. Think about how you might change your future actions to avoid this situation.
在经历了一次失误之后，无论那是什么，反思它带给你的感受同样至关重要。你知道的，你是否以一种你并不真正希望的方式让某人重新回到了你的生活里？或者如果你觉得自己又去找了那个你不想再依赖的人，不要压抑这种感觉。几乎不要压抑那种羞耻感。去面对它。去消化它。想想你该如何改变未来的行动来避免这种情况。
Be future looking. Imagine where you would like to be. Be like, okay, last night I went over to this person's house and I helped them out, even though I know this is codependent, even though I really want some separation. And now I feel really bad. I feel really, really crap about it. myself. Instead of being like, oh my God, I don't want to feel that. That's really uncomfortable. Allow yourself to feel that way and then look to the future. And I guess that applies for everything, not just breaking free of codependency. When we look towards the future, our progress is going to be more steady. Obviously, you can follow these steps. You can take my advice, do everything right, but the thing is about any relationship is that it's always complicated, it's always nuanced, and
放眼未来。想象一下你希望自己身在何处。去想想：好吧，昨晚我去了那个人的家，我帮了他们，尽管我知道这是一种共生，尽管我真的很想保持一些距离。而现在我感觉糟透了。我对自己感觉非常非常糟糕。与其告诉自己“天哪，我不想有这种感觉，这太难受了”，不如允许自己去感受这种情绪，然后展望未来。我想这适用于所有事情，而不仅仅是摆脱共生关系。当我们展望未来时，我们的进步才会更加稳健。当然，你可以遵循这些步骤。你可以采纳我的建议，把所有事情都做好，但任何关系的问题在于，它总是复杂的、微妙的，而且
you know what you're going through more than I ever could. So take it slow. Be kind to yourself. And I really hope that this information has helped you. I feel like I've learnt so much from this discussion and this research, especially about so many of the misconceptions around codependency and how we can distinguish it from healthy dependency and interdependency. It's just such a fascinating topic, especially for our 20s, where I feel like a lot of us have really intense relationships with people, whether that is, you know, really good friends or the people that we're dating. And it can really feel like it's just us too in this bubble and one of us is really reliant on the other person and is taking so much and the other person
你所经历的事情，比我所能想象的要多得多。所以放慢脚步。对你自己好一点。我真的希望这些信息对你有所帮助。我觉得从这次讨论和研究中我学到了太多，尤其是关于围绕共生关系的诸多误解，以及我们如何将其与健康的依赖和相互依赖区分开来。这真的是一个非常迷人的话题，特别是在我们二十多岁的时候，我觉得我们很多人都与人有着非常强烈的情感关系，无论是很好的朋友还是我们在约会的人。这种感觉真的就像这个气泡里只有我们俩，其中一个人极度依赖另一个人，索取了太多，而另一个人
can't leave. And it's just really emotionally volatile. So if you can relate, you deserve a lot of credit. I'm sure it's really difficult. But hopefully this episode gave you some sense of the future and some sense of what you can do. Thank you for listening today. I think that's all that we have time for. I'm really hopeful and, yeah, hoping that you enjoyed it. I really did as well. So if you did enjoy this episode, if you learned something, that's the most important. Please feel free to leave a five-star review on Apple Podcast, Spotify, wherever you are listening right now. If you want to follow us on Instagram, that's where I let my listeners decide. what I record for the next week so you can contribute to what you want to hear.
却无法离开。这种情绪真的很不稳定。所以，如果你能感同身受，你真的值得好好夸奖自己。我确信这一定非常艰难。但希望这一集能给你一些对未来的方向感，以及一些你可以做的事情。谢谢你今天的收听。我想我们今天的时间就到这里了。我真的充满期待，而且，是的，希望你喜欢它。我也真的很喜欢。所以，如果你喜欢这一集，如果你学到了东西，那才是最重要的。请随时在苹果播客、Spotify或你现在收听节目的任何地方留下五星好评。如果你想在Instagram上关注我们，我会在那里让听众决定我下一周录制什么内容，这样你就可以为你想听的内容贡献一份力量。
And thank you so much for listening. Thank you so much for tuning in. I feel very grateful that people want to hear what we're discussing and people are interested in these topics as much as I am and are willing to learn as much as I really like learning. So thank you so much for joining us for this journey and have an absolutely lovely week. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really
非常感谢你们的收听。非常感谢你们的调频收听。我感到非常感激，大家想听我们讨论的内容，并且对这些话题和我一样感兴趣，也愿意像我一样去学习。非常感谢你们和我一起踏上这段旅程，祝你们度过绝对美好的一周。嘿，最近怎么样，各位？欢迎收听《艰难成长的学问》（Learn the Hardway），我是你们最喜欢的治疗师和主持人，盖恩斯（Games）。这个空间聚焦于黑人男性的经历，进行那些在其他任何地方都
not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the IHare radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test once.
根本不安全去进行的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士交流。有多少男人披着铠甲？这向世界发出了一个信号：你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《艰难成长的学问》。2023年，美国单身汉明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控生下了一对双胞胎。但这似乎是一个骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这份特定的测试两次，对吧？我伪造了一次测试。
It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian. Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is love trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police.
网络侦探们倾巢而出，才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一个女同性恋。迈克尔·马拉蒂尼（Michael Marantini）。我的大脑都要炸裂了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《深陷爱河》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。
As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faced. consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%.
随着节目的播出，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面对了后果。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《深陷爱河》播客。2%。这就是当旁边有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人所占的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了精神韧性、健身以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你最终就会成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。收听《2%》。
That's TWO%. On the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this.
也就是“TWO%”。在iHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他的最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。
He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友们。听女朋友的话。相信我，宝贝，在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。这是一个iHeart播客。百分之百真人保证。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。